is Q&A entrepreneurship league of
legends answering questions they it's
Tuesday we have rishi cup TV in the
house how you doing Rishi whoo I'm
feeling good thanks for having me Evan
and good morning believe nation we got
Jay rise on the game with me here today
so this should be some fun times o Jays
back in the game yeah Jays in the game
he set it up he was having some tech
issues but we sorted that out so we're
good to go ah it's a little sore from
recording yesterday so I got a cup of
nettle tea with honey what's in your cup
machine alright this morning I got a cup
of coconut coffee what what's coconut
coffee it's actually really not that
wonderful it's good coconut flavored
coffee folgers style it sounds wonderful
it tastes good i'll have to say folgers
does well with a few of their flavored
coffees all right I'm liking it and yeah
what what's the what's the value would
baptize feeling today I'm just feeling
um I have to really feel this because
you told us in our gratitude stream like
you know you got to really feel your
gratitude so I'm going to play off of
our gratitude stream I am feeling a cup
of gratitude for this amazing community
support that I don't know that you will
find anywhere else in entrepreneurship
no I agree man i love i love that that's
great i love it i'm just going to close
the blinds actually so don't get some
Sun on me while I'm playing how good
all right well we're live on twitch I
see Zeno in the house already time for
another great live stream and five saw
somewhere about predicting a win
predicting the wind I actually looked at
my stats last night and I I have more
losses on t-mo than wins overall so this
is some crazy record streak that we're
on here that hopefully we can continue
and what a lot of the streamers do or
make me have the streamers with like
when they upload to YouTube because all
these we just go to my youtube channel
what a lot of them do is only post their
big wins or they like whether they got
lots of kills and they won they never
post their losses so i want you guys to
know that I lose a lot just hasn't
happened yet on the live stream all
right well we're waiting we're waiting
for a game to start let's get into let's
give me some questions so what do we got
all right first question come from uh
nay Smee I gotta tell you hey I gotta
tell you and I've I've learned names on
this dream that I've you know never seen
anywhere else before so shut out for all
of you that was the unique name I love
it you know what I want to see more
unique names I want to see more yeah or
if you want Rishi to call you a name as
long as it's you know PG friendly
they're like say no spider-man or
something you know oh that would be very
cool I'm sure I spell like he's gotta
like something's come on saying what do
you want us to call you something okay
I'm jungle and Jays mid so we got it
that's our usual mix that's our ideal
mix it's starting off well all right
first question
okay so basically looks like she's in
South Africa 31 years old and wants to
start a cooking business it's her
passion one day she wants to own a
restaurant but a part of her concern is
that she's not getting any support from
friends and family she has an
opportunity actually to be a part of a
mentorship incubator program and you
know I think it'll is going to provide
her even more business skills and
qualifications to pursue her goals but
she's just concerned she's taken the
wrong path so yeah that's a pretty
common question and dilemma for those of
us who are trying to carve our own path
and you know I just kind of think snay
sorry if I'm saying that wrong but I
just kind of think that this is part of
this is the normal and natural part of
the process and it's easier to do what
everyone says is the more reasonable
rational decision and it's not because
they don't love you it's not because
they don't care obviously it's your
family and friends and sometimes people
are just concerned and there's nothing
wrong with getting feedback that
challenges you but I think at the end of
the day your your your path is going to
be most meaningful when you listen to
what it is that you want to do and and
you carve your own way and it is harder
and it may take longer and you will have
doubters but that is not abnormal to
anyone who's had to do it and so I think
if you can just accept it as kind of the
normal
the normal terrain of an entrepreneur
what it what to expect on the journey
you will have people along the way who
are going to tell you why it's not going
to work and that's normal and that's
that means you're on to something so I'm
going to just encourage you to keep
going for it and it sounds like this
incubator program and and mentorship is
a great widdit at least at the very
least get more skills to prepare you for
your cooking passion Dallas something to
build that question at the end seemed a
little off to me I got the start so you
know she wants to be a co 2 instead of
restaurant is an incubator program her
family doesn't support her um got it
well how did she end it what does he say
at the end there she just said but
through all of it it's been hard because
my family and my friends think that I'm
taking the wrong path okays because they
think that she's taking their own pen
right I mean that's the conflict it he
feels is it gonna be the wrong path
because she's getting that from her
loved one sure record I got it yeah i
mean i agree with thought of what r if
she said it is super common oops
download that it is super common and you
know i was fortunate enough to have
parents that supported mean whatever I
wanted to do but I had friends who
didn't who didn't believe in my you know
my turning down 80 to 100 thousand
dollar starting salary jobs job that
they wanted and me turning them down
that was the smart thing to do to go do
my business who are making three hundred
dollars a month you know one understand
that for the most part is out of love
right you know your parents they want to
see you be successful they want to see
you you know have a happy life they just
see it through their eyes they see the
world through their eyes and their
experiences
and they would never do anything so
crazy and so they're just trying to help
you avoid pain at some point though you
have to figure out again whether it's
you're like are you living your life or
your parents version of your life you
know and as you grow up you know you're
living you say yes to the parents and
you follow their rules and you might
have a little bit of rule-breaking along
the way but at some point you know
you're an adult you gotta start making
decisions for yourself and it made it
may be worth having like if you're sold
on this this is what you want to do and
really for me would be we talked about
this yesterday regret like will you
regret not taking this will you regret
not going to this incubator program and
taking a chance and betting on yourself
and for me it's I'm ok with the failure
of what I'm not okay with is not knowing
how would work out right like this this
live League of Legends dream or my
gratitude stream that we just came from
I'm okay with it being a failure I'm
okay with nobody showing up I'm okay
with it not taking off but I need to
know that it's not going to work I need
to I need to try you know like like that
girl or guy that you really want to talk
to but you're afraid it's okay to get
rejected but you have to the least tries
that you know and so that would be my
fear for you is that you take the safe
path and you don't get confirmation you
don't experiment you don't try it and as
a result for the rest of your life
you're thinking man I really wish I did
it and and you know then maybe you start
to resent your parents or you resent
your friends and you blame them for not
believing in you more we're really it's
on you write like this this is your
decision they may not support you but
it's it's your decision whether to go
forward or not and I think if you've
committed to doing it and you know you
really want to do it and you
don't want to live with regret for the
rest of your life then the key is to sit
down with them and let just let them
know really how important it is to you
that you're okay with failure that
you're not going to try to take you know
big risks you know you're gonna you're
not going to invest your life savings
into this you're going to step your way
into it but you need to know you need to
know like you cannot live without
knowing if this will work or not and
that you really need their support to
like their support matters to you you
know my friends their support didn't
matter to me you know my parents raised
me that I'm like to make me believe that
I could do anything I wanted and so I
just do whether people like it so I
don't I don't need approval of my
friends and people around me to go and
try something I just go out and I do it
but but telling you're telling your
parents telling your friends that like
their support really mean something to
you and that you really want to try this
its end really hard it's really hard for
them not to to be on board and then not
to wanted to help you out so but that's
that's my advice and I feel for you and
I think it's something that a lot of
entrepreneurs have to go through as esri
she said but if you really want to do it
really want to take your shot you gotta
know then you have to go and do it you
gotta try
absolutely absolutely and along the way
you will find those people and you know
if you go into the incubator program and
get involved in community of food lovers
you will find the people who support you
oh yeah and it's I think again like what
really helps at least helps me is you
read the stories and you see people who
it obviously works out well for and that
and that can be a great story I mean wow
worked out well for you you said no to
your parents and your friends and just
went out and did it and that's amazing
and awesome and you're all happy but the
key at least for me it's also being oh
we just gotta our team lost my life we
got they got first blood I'm not happy
about this oh the key for me is being
being okay with the failure to like if
it doesn't work out I'm gonna be okay
and I'm okay because I got the the
certainty I know I know that it didn't
work out there's knowing that it didn't
work out is better than not knowing at
all at least for me and so that helps me
get through a lot of the fear or anxiety
in trying something new and like the
upside is great the upside is you have a
career in a life that you're happy with
in your having an impact and making
money and all of these great wonderful
things but even if none of it works out
even if you're you know even if
everything's a total failure it's still
a win because you know and that
certainty is great we got a we got de
masta back in the house today all right
welcome back damask I think is that it's
de master like they were talking about
it I saw in the chapter for the master
like like the master not that his name
is de masta but welcome at da Mosta I
think Zeno i discovered that i got food
de masta oh yeah i thought it was some
kind of like reggae hello now vodka did
you have anything rishi growing up or
more recently where you really wanted to
do something but people around you
weren't as supportive of they could have
been oh gosh I where do I start so
recently I did have a conversation with
a friend of mine and so for those of you
who actually don't follow my channel its
suppo year and a half old and I shared
yesterday that my commitment to the
channel was really a commitment to
myself that I would it would be a place
where I would you know honor acknowledge
what the whole name and who I am because
in the past I've been certain jobs like
I was the dancer or I was the singer but
I was never like all of the things that
I felt would make my career most
meaningful anyway I had a friend
recently who you know express that and
I'm sorry the only reason to putter face
is I'm Turnham i'll take at go on our
call oh ok i'll turn you down to my in
the polio okay don't yeah i just had
this conversation my friend about how he
was too like you've really changed you
know
and it it was a hard conversation to
have because she was expressing that the
person that you need to be was not who I
was becoming and it wasn't that really
she wasn't in support of me but i think
it was like trying to understand why am
i changing um I guess I guess whether
it's an awesome son oriole thing or not
you know when you're pursuing who you
want to be and you really are trying to
be true to the path that you're on it
may mean that who you were and how
people know you is not who you are
becoming so the conversation ended well
and she isn't in the category of like a
hater but she was someone who was
basically expressing that me changing
was difficult for her to understand and
it did it did make it hard on a
relationship but I guess I had to settle
within myself that I am not found to be
who I who I was I you know nothing who I
was before was was wrong I mean it was
I'm just I'm willing to commit to be
coming I want to become the person that
I'm you know kind of purposed to be and
and so that means that I might need to
just be willing to grow in new ways and
try new things and that may may mean
people don't understand and it just is
kind of part of the process denied I
kind of settled that within myself and
yeah so that's one of many situations i
think we're me kind of pursuing my heart
passion meaningful work has created
conflict and relationship than that
that's sort of a thing
hmm and I think it's important that as
people you know you grow as a human
being you evolve you know the person you
were growing up is not the same person
you're going to be now and the good test
of friendships is that as you both grow
together they're able to support and
understand the decisions you're making
and same thing with you like nothing
you're doing is trying to hurt that
friend of yours right it's not it's not
saying you know you're wrong and I'm
doing this out of malice and I want to I
want to hurt you right you're just doing
what you feel is best for you and
sometimes people can appreciate that and
sometimes they can't but you don't want
that to be the reason why you don't take
action mm-hmm that because you won't you
won't forgive that person and you will
forgive yourself if you don't do
something because your mom and your best
friend or somebody in your life told you
that that's a stupid decision yeah
at the game going the game is not going
well haha we are at I haven't done it I
haven't done much yet I've tried to get
in and do some stuff but it hasn't
worked and the team is has we're behind
we got three kills and eight deaths so
but you know what Jay horizon hicieron a
game is always is always hope so we'll
see we'll see I like a challenge great
all right um next question comes from
sue brothel that's great that's a great
name to Brussels and stupid also is
asking about okay so he is a um we're
distancing what he is he's an
instrumentation sales engineer in India
and he is having a problem because
sometimes what happens is his client
start asking questions which are totally
outside of their boundaries on the
subject and on commercial negotiation
negotiation and he becomes irritable and
I guess when he he kind of gets me gets
irritable and he starts losing business
what should I do in these conditions
about what the clients don't even want
to listen about the technicalities of
the product so yeah hopefully that did I
did you get that question um evident
that I died I was in Illinois explain
why you were reading and I died and so I
could use it again so he's he's he's
trying to sell his stuff to customers
but they're not do not getting it there
become we were two bullies know how to
pitch himself is that it yeah it sounds
like when they start asking questions
which he considers her outside of bounds
of what they you know him being the one
who knows more about the engineering of
the product and and the costs of the
product when they start getting out of
bounds and their questions
he just gets really irritable and but it
quick and then it he loses the client
got it yes that's it okay I like it yeah
so this is I think whether you're an
engineer or you know someone who is got
a specialization in a certain area and
you're dealing customers that don't have
that same expertise I think you run into
this conflict of how can I you know how
can I do what I know I can do and also
please my client and I think it's um
it's a you gotta have a balance there of
knowing how to be there for your client
because at the end of the day your
client is your bed it's going to keep
you business and so if you're getting
irritable and you're and you're losing
your clients as a problem I I would just
suggest you know maybe maybe it's time
to hire someone who is somewhat of a
liaison between you and the client you
know someone who can be a better people
person and help educate your clients in
a way that they feel comfortable with
the information they understand and you
know it's also someone who's in who
enjoys communicating with the client but
if you if you don't have the ability to
hire someone then I would say you would
have to learn how to deal with people in
a way where they're not going to feel
like you know you're not willing to
serve their their needs and their
questions because you know it's at the
end of the day it really is about being
there for them and making sure that they
feel supported and invaluable
I like it um are one of our players quit
the game so this will be interesting to
see what happens we are six kills and 12
deaths so we're behind and we're playing
four against five so this will be a fun
challenge I think you have two options
similar along the lines what Rishi said
you're either learn to get better either
learn to value and appreciate the client
and recognize that these guys are
bringing you business and they are your
livelihood or you don't and you work
with people who can appreciate what you
bring and the thing is your stuff better
be like if you're a good people person
then you can appeal to a lot of a lot of
people right people like working with
you if you're not you know then the
stuff that you have has to be so good
that they'll deal with you being really
crabby and upset and angry all the time
so if you can go Rishi's room and hire
somebody or you can partner with
somebody who has those people skills and
who is the buffer and who can deal with
you and your crappiness or you just work
at finding clients who will listen to
you and who can deal with you you know I
look at myself an example I don't
consider myself to be a crabby person
hopefully that doesn't that's not the
the aura I'm throwing off but I will
work with very few clients I turned down
more clients and I get or then I say yes
to and it's usually because i don't like
we're not aligned philosophically
okay I'm not that even they're bad
people or not that they're not willing
to listen they're just like what they
want to do does not match up with what I
want to do and so I don't want to work
with them and it doesn't have to be a
mean thing like you know I'm so much
better than you and you guys suck and
you know however how would that man is
best for you for you but um at the same
time though I I can be selectively you
know I have I have what I provide is so
valuable that most people can't do what
I do and so when it works out really
well is when the clients recognize the
value that I bring they recognize that
I'm one of the best in the world of what
I do they want to take my advice they
want to grow and that's a beautiful
relationship and for people who don't
value what I do who you know might try
to nickel and dime is it hey can it be
you know gonna be a lot cheaper or can
you do it this way or changing up my
process that I know kind of won't work
or did I feel it below my standards and
I don't work with them so that may be
kind of a third option between you
getting better at talking to customers
in boom you potentially hiring somebody
or partnering with somebody or just
being really specific on the kinds of
clans that you want to work with and
then be able to provide insane value to
those people right look if you're
selling if you're selling mazda cars you
can't take that approach but if you're
selling you know Ferrari as you can so
what are you selling if you're selling a
mass-market kind of stuff of you if
you're bit like you know I look at my
Jonathan salsa business you know alex is
fantastic and dealing with people we
need that he's looking at him he heard
his name he's looking over it matter
you heard the fantastic good laughing
Alex fantastic might be your new name
Alex fantastic he's here working um
that's the kind of business you know a
class is just over a hundred dollars
it's a mass business right that business
makes money by reaching a lot of people
if we don't reach a lot of people were
not we're not it's not a luxury kind of
market where what I do the consulting
work that I may do what the brands at
work with is much more luxury it's less
price sensitive and so I don't need to
be a super friendly person although i
feel like i am but i don't think the
dress I don't need to be as I can be
more selective so it depends on what
this guy is trying to build and sell the
penya on that market depending on the
company that is in it can alter his
approach a key and it does that I am I
gonna get killed no I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die I died very sad
this is a rough game this is going to be
this is likely a loss here playing 4v5
yeah I don't think you should be beast
that Avenue need to speak believe right
now sleepily I believe in our loss I
believe in hahaha well when when one
player is out when you're playing four
against five it's uh it's it's super
hard to win anyway but the fact that
we're already like way behind we'll see
i'm still fighting today I'm still
fighting it out you see what happens all
right what else oh right my team
surrendered my team surrendered so
that's it oh yeah we lost o gg gg his
good game GG is getting that was fast we
may have time to do another one I wonder
how many question like to yeah we do
have time if you want to try um we've
got plenty more we've only done three
today so okay all right I'm gonna
nu-uh I'm good I want to I want to ask
Alex when you put in that coffee because
it's the first time I think that we
ought oh you're putting the loss on
Alex's coffee Wow Alex yeah take your
headphone this is the first time that I
lost I heard this is the first time you
gotta you gotta you gotta come in here
so people can see this is there's Alex
this is the first time that I lost in
like I don't know how many like 15 games
or something in Rishi my co-host is
putting the blame on the coffee Alex put
in the caller I feel the love yeah I put
love into the coffee and if I like a lot
of them you can blame that I can't
handle the love that's what it is handle
of can another bromance love give me
give me more hate hate goes well people
in the chat say I still love you Alex oh
oh thank you guys that loss wasn't on
you so no cup up cup of love Alex it's
all love tough love all right okay well
let's see what we got here ok good
question alright next question comes
from henrik henrik is 26 years old from
sweden and starting a business and so
this is an interesting question because
henrik has come up with a method where
basically this method helps you learn
anything more efficiently and get better
at at something quicker he himself for
example spent two years you know
practicing piano and got accepted into
one of the most coveted music
universities in scandinavia and you know
was going up against guys who had had a
lifetime of experience piano so using
this method he was able to to go you
know extreme with his piano skills he
also ended up in the top point five
percent six million people playing a
competitive video game there you go ok
so i guess this method is something that
he wants to
you know put into a form of a business
and he wanted to know from you just you
know is there a label for someone who is
helping others make their time more
efficient and getting better quicker
yeah he wants to become the best in the
world at teaching people with this
method so you know I personally don't
know that there's a label for something
like this I certainly you could spend
time googling and seeing what's out
there for you know methods educational
methods rise online says polymaths in
the chat but I what comes to mind
actually immediately is like you know
why don't you create a label the Mosta
said an acceleration coach yeah i mean
great great definitely i was thinking
coach could be a label you could give
yourself but what came to mind is is
like why don't you innovate and create a
label and create this industry that you
you are tapping into because once you
innovate and become the first to do it
you know you end up inevitably
dominating and leading so i don't know
you know Tony Robbins he was the first
person to create this coach you know
model and then I think Howard Schultz
seven on your wall the first to kind of
tap into that starbucks model here so i
say be the first and innovate and you
know i'm not saying it's going to be
easy but it will make you be definitely
the leader in that particular industry
got a lot of other are great suggestions
in the chat like yeah creo que no
there's just some okay good good good
chat going on in the live comments I
think coach is just overplayed I feel
like everybody's a coach sit oh we got a
game going I'm glad this look that this
question deeply upsets me but but i also
have a lot of it with me i also have a
lot of empathy because who cares what
your name is like you're using this time
to ask one question to help you grow
your business and the most important
thing on your mind right now is what am
I going to call myself it doesn't matter
like does it matter sure but in the look
it's nowhere near close to the top of
priorities whether you call yourself a
performance coach or guru or you make
something up like it doesn't matter it's
nowhere near the top of where you need
to be focusing on and and I'm the reason
why I'm upset is because my goal with
all of this stuff is to have an impact
on the people asking the question in the
audience and I feel like I can't because
I don't know the real problem that this
guy is facing right now and so we're
addressing some surface of the surface
level issue that isn't super important
if you're really good at teaching if
you're really going to do it yourself to
start you're really good at getting into
piano and learning you're really good at
figuring out a video game and being the
best then first then you got to figure
out can you teach you to others right
just because you're really good let me
bandage ampion here just because you're
really good at doing something doesn't
mean that you're going to be a great
teacher you look at a lot of the hitting
coaches in baseball you look at Ted
Williams for those baseball fans we
don't one of the greatest hitters of all
time if not the greatest depending on
how you rank hitters and then he became
a hitting coach any socks like he
couldn't transfer his knowledge of how
to do something over to
somebody else and so that's that's the
next skill that you need to learn since
you're so good at picking up skills you
need to figure out how you can transfer
that to other people and so you start by
testing right like well how can you take
everybody has goals everyone wants to
get better or something you know maybe
Rishi wants to be a better singer or a
better youtuber or a better cook or a
better friend or better you know
whatever it is fill in the blank we all
want to get better at something you know
teach me how to be a better team o teach
me how to win that last game right and
then doing that or doing that for for
bigger-name people doing that on stage
doing that where there's an audience
right like if you came on and taught me
how to be better at youtube and it
worked you would get instant fans you
would get people who want to work with
you you want you to get people who want
to buy your products your ebook your
coaching program whatever it is but you
have to show that it works you may want
to stick with in a niche like if you
want to do gaming great there's tons of
big gamers you know we have this channel
but this isn't really a gaming channel
but if you know if you start with a
smaller channel and help that guy climb
and get better at the game and then keep
working your way up you'll get you get
attention you get awareness to get
people who want to work with you and
they won't care if you call yourself the
performance coach or Billy Bob man you
know like it doesn't it's nowhere near
the most important thing you need to
worry about some upset cuz I want to
help this guy and I feel like it did but
I want to help more but I have empathy
to like people don't necessarily know
what to ask or how to do it but for
those of you worrying about your name
yeah the name can help but I don't
believe in calling yourself what you
actually do